- If I was a real genie,
or a real fucking Yoda,
and I was like
yo, check this out,
watch this, and you saw you,
fuck, what the fuck,
and you saw you,
and it's a good life,
and I'm like
here's all you gotta do,
you gotta work 15
hours a day right now
for the next ten years straight,
you'll do it,
everybody will do it.
People don't do it
because they're not sure
what's on the other side of it.
Because they said no
before they said yes.
(rap music)
("Mrs. Jones" by ItsSeanMC)
In 2018, Amazon
Alexa is gonna be
in four different car makers,
involved in the car.
So literally
2018, Tesla, Ford,
two others,
literally, it's in the car.
And it's a time saver.
It's Uber.
Uber got real big
because it saves and sells time,
Sound Voice sells time.
Alexa Skills sells time,
podcasts sell time.
So I really wanna bet on it,
I wanna make sure everybody
here in all their disciplines...
- [Man] How does
podcasts save time?
- Because listening
is a passive behavior,
so you can listen and
go through your email.
You can't watch my video
and go through your email.
- [Man] Got it.
- Got it?
And we are now getting trained
to be able to multi-consume,
so we're watching
TV and on our phone,
we're in multi-consumption zone,
our brains are
getting behavioral.
- [Man 2] You don't
download them too, so...
You don't have wifi problems,
a lot of the video
problems with stuff
when you're digesting
is you don't have signal,
podcasts people are
downloading previously,
they have the access...
- It's also easier
to listen to a podcast
while you're working out
than watch a video
when you're working out.
It's just saving time.
I think the open, white space,
because I'm
really paying attention,
is multiple guests
at the same time.
- [Woman] You think?
- Uh-huh.
So I think the big
white space is two guests,
with you, that ying and yang,
- [Woman] Oh two,
not more than... yeah.
- Yeah, two. Two guests.
There's a lot of two hosts,
there's a lot of two hosts,
that's classic
Mike and the Mad Dog,
like that's been around.
Two guests at the same time,
back to John Favreau's
Dinner with Four.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- There's a dynamic
when you get multiple...
I'm a little
worried about a third guest,
'cause crossing wires.
I do think two is very...
And that is
something nobody is doing,
and I think that
can be the breakthrough.
And I think that
looks like you get
the fancy fashion designer,
and then you get the
Brooklyn fashion designer,
or you get the A-list celebrity,
and you get the influencer,
or you get the...
I'm very, very, very comfortable
being on the offense.
To me it's like this.
How I think
about it Jeff is this.
I think of it as... somebody's
gonna get an Easter egg.
Somebody's gonna read
this and be like what the fuck?
So to me, London, LA,
SMB, that's out here.
So whatever the proper is,
like New York media business,
we need to make sure...
This 80 needs to
run on its profit,
and then we make these bets
because our
upside grows from that.
Got it? That's how
I think about it.
That's the
framework I think under.
- What's up man, good to see ya.
- Hey man, how are ya?
- Pleasure to meet ya.
- Really nice to meet you.
- How you doing man?
- Nice to meet you man.
- Real pleasure.
Yeah, continued
success, we'll be in touch.
Send me that.
- Yeah I will.
- Hey Mike, hey Paula...
Hey Shoots, how are ya?
Good, now I can hear.
Yeah, so Mike obviously I'd
love to answer any questions,
I think we've
had a basic framework
of what we're
thinking about here,
but I wanted to answer
anything for you and Tyler
that I could to continue
moving the ball forward.
Tyler, the real reason is
I wanna make the investment
that you're making worthwhile,
and I feel like if
there's more than four people
I'm diluting it. You know?
That's why I never
wanna build this model.
I only wanna sell
things I believe in.
Can you guys hold
on for one second?
- [Amber] Hi I'm such a big fan.
- Thank you.
- My name is Amber.
- Thank you Amber.
- I just walked by and I saw it,
I was like oh my
god, that's Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm great.
Can we take a selfie?
- Sure.
- Oh my God.
Oh wait, that
takes it the wrong way.
- I'm sorry, I'm like...
- No worries.
- So taken up right now.
Thank you so much!
- So nice to meet you.
- It was so nice to meet you!
- Thank you, take care.
Mike, I'm running late
to this thing right now,
I can get back on
the phone with you guys,
or you can email me this,
but in theory I
wanna overdeliver,
so why don't you
guys get all the asks
and let me see what I can do.
- Gary this is Jason Fowl,
he works on custom content here
and we just
bumped into each other.
- Awesome.
- [Jason] GaryVee, Jason Feifer.
- [Gary] Jason,
how are you, man?
- [Jason] What's going on, man?
Good to see you.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- Yeah, thanks for popping in.
- [Gary] How are things?
Thrilled to be here,
thrilled to be here.
- [Jason] Good,
good, great to have you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Jason] Welcome to the action.
- [Gary] I love it.
- [Jason] It's a
quiet news world,
but that's what action is.
- [Gary] I get it.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- [Jason] All right,
here, you want ...
This is the box.
- This is it, huh?
- This is it, this is it.
This is the first
time I've ever actually had
someone come into
the magazine to get
their copy of the magazine?
- I love it.
- It's amazing.
- I like doing
first time things.
- Yeah, that's great.
- This is awesome, man.
- I'm Rebecca.
- It's a lot of fun.
Hey, Rebecca.
- [Rebecca] So nice to meet you.
Thank you for everything.
- Great to meet you,
great to meet you.
- Hello, hi, how are you?
- [Jason] Hey everyone, GaryVee.
- Hey, guys.
- [Group] Hey.
- Thank you for
making me look so good.
I appreciate it.
- [Woman 2] Hi.
[Gary] Hi.
- [Woman 3] Congratulations on
being on the cover.
- [Gary] Thank you,
thank you, hi.
- Congratulations
on being on the cover.
- [Gary] Good to
see you, how are you?
- Good, how are you?
- [Gary] Good to see you, hey.
- Hey, great to meet you.
Dan, nice to meet you.
- Dan, such a pleasure.
- Yeah, thanks for coming.
- Hey, guys, how are you?
Thanks for having me.
- [Woman 4] So nice to meet you.
- I don't know if you want it,
but this is--
- I'll take it.
- It came first of the,
you know when the--
- I'll definitely take, here.
- [Rebecca] Collector's item.
- Yeah, I can.
- Yeah, take it.
When they come
first off, they send us
like three or four of those.
- [Gary] I love it.
- So I hung on to one for you.
- Is it weird to
look at your face
on the cover of a magazine?
- It's super fun.
Honestly, you know,
I mean for me it's, I'd be lying
if I didn't say it's like, yeah.
- Put this in your
shirt, just hanging out front.
- Just let it hang out a bit.
- Yeah.
- It's a super kind
of like dream come true
for an entrepreneur
to be on the cover
of Entrepreneur
Magazine, you know.
- Yeah.
- It's super, it's super fun.
Like, I'm super pumped about it.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- I can't wait to
get texts, or emails,
or Facebook messages
from like high school friends.
- [Jason] Totally.
- You know, it's funny.
This is actually
probably a really good month
to be on the
cover of a magazine,
because so many people travel
for Memorial Day weekend.
- Yeah, it's true.
- Right?
So like, the
airport action is real.
- [Man 3] It's a good point.
- That's where people see shit
- Yeah.
When they don't normally see it.
So, I was like yeah,
this is probably good.
- Yeah, you know
that's really interesting
because today--
- I was literally like,
ooh, I hope July's issue
is like slowed down by accident
so I can catch 4th of July, too.
(laughs)
I was getting
real evil with my--
- Imagining.
- Yeah.
- Our July/August
issue is combined.
- Oh, is that right?
- So, we push it out late.
- Yes, dude you just
literally made my life.
Literally today I was
like wouldn't it be amazing
if they had some
weird thing happen
for, oh you have a July--
- August, yeah.
I'm here with Gary Vaynerchuk,
the cover man for the
100 Brilliant Ideas issue.
Also, you know digitally,
the word ideas is so huge
for us because those stories
that say you need an idea.
Here are ways to find ideas.
Those things always
do really well for us.
By the way,
I should introduce myself.
I'm Jason Feifer.
I'm the Editor In Chief
of Entrepreneur Magazine,
and I'm here, again,
with Gary Vaynerchuk.
Gary, let's talk about ideas.
- Sure.
- I wanted you on this cover
because you are so full of them.
I think that you also
inspire people to have ideas.
I think the big
question for a lot of people
is if they've got the energy,
they've got the drive,
they know they
can put in the work,
but they don't have the
idea to focus all of that.
You know? They don't have
the business idea.
- Yeah.
- Where do the ideas come from?
- I think the best way
to come up with an idea
is to reverse engineer what
your day to day looks like.
I actually think
the ideas are directly
in front of your face.
I think the biggest problem
with a lot of entrepreneurs
is they're so
hungry to build a business,
or to be an
entrepreneur, that they're
sitting around trying
to come up with the idea
which then immediately
takes you out of
usually the best idea.
The best idea is,
I'll never forget it,
when Garrett Camp
talked about Uber
he literally said,
"Hey, we have iPhones now.
"Wouldn't it be cool
if you could get a limo
"by pressing a button?"
Of course, I remember saying
that's only for rich people.
Wrong, but, I think
the ideas are, to me,
the number one idea on earth
is scratching your own itch.
If you're living your
life and you say that sucked,
well you've got a business.
Because, we really value time.
We value convenience, and
so I would walk around life,
judge what stinks,
and see if there's a way
to make it better, and
then hopefully you're not
an anomaly and the only
one that thinks it stinks.
To me, that's,
the idea comes to you,
not you go and say, "Today I'm
going to come up with ... "
Nobody does that.
- Mhmmm.
- People do it
from an intuition.
Then, it evolves.
- Yeah, but how do you test
it out, right, because--
- By doing.
- No, but let's stay here.
- Yeah.
- By doing.
- Mhmmm.
Everybody thinks
that they have to like
manifest this idea
over time, and come up
with it perfect,
and then you go.
- Yeah.
- Ideas evolve.
You get a seed.
Microsoft wasn't
was Microsoft was.
Facebook isn't remotely
close to what Facebook...
You've got to
start with something.
The biggest thing
that's crippling entrepreneurs
from winning is
their lack of doing.
- That they hold on too long.
- 100%. They
romanticise around the idea.
They think they've got an idea,
and then they spend the rest
of this summer debating it
until they're
seven months later,
and they haven't done anything.
- Yeah.
- And then it
just loses it's energy.
- Mhmmm.
- For me,
I appreciate you saying
I have a lot of good ideas.
I have a good track record
because the second
I think I've got something.
- You do it.
- I go.
I go.
- Yeah.
- And I lose money,
and I don't lose money,
and I try, and
I taste, and I adjust,
and I stop.
I'm not scared
that somebody says that,--
- That's a bad idea.
- Didn't work.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- My dad used to yell at me.
He was like, "You
always change your mind.
"You said last year that we
would never sell rosÊ wine."
I'm like, "I changed my mind."
- Mhmmm.
And it's okay to
change your mind.
It's okay to--
- It's the cost of entry
to be an entrepreneur.
- Yeah.
- I always tell my
team at the agency,
"You know what's subjective?
"Creative."
Creative's subjective
before it hits the world,
then it plays out.
I go, "You know
what's not creative?
"Deadlines."
Excuse me, subjective.
You know what's not subjective?
Deadlines.
- Yeah.
- If a client
wants it on Tuesday,
you better put
something in front of them.
If you come on Thursday
because you guys all
debated it to be perfect,
and then you put it
in front of somebody,
and they don't like it?
Then you've lost twice.
- Mhmmm.
- I think that's right.
I'm thrilled to hear that
you guys deployed that speed,
and I think the necessity
of deadline and small team,
is a huge advantage.
You should always take,
Listen, if you're David,
play David's game.
If you're Goliath,
play Goliath's game.
And I think,
for all the entrepreneurs
that are watching right now,
play to your strengths.
- Yeah.
Last question and then,--
- then we'll let you
get on with your day.
How do you know,
as you said, the key
to knowing if an
idea is good is doing.
How do you know when to stop?
How do you know when
to move to the next idea,
if it's not working.
- There's only two things.
The market tells you
or you tell yourself.
You move on when
nobody's buying your shit.
If you're like, "But I
knew this was going to work,"
and nobody's buying it,
the market told you to move on.
I really think
you're going to buy this,
and they start buying it,
and you're doing great,
but somehow you're
waking up miserable everyday,
it's time to move on.
So no golden handcuffs, right?
Don't let the dollar
amount get you to a place
where 30 years later,
you look back,
You might have made some money,
but you were
miserable for 30 years.
- Yeah.
- The other one's very easy.
The market tells you to move on.
- Mhmmm.
- So the only decision
you have to make is
if it's going well,
are you enjoying it enough
for the financial benefit.
And if you're not,
you have to move on.
- Yeah, yeah.
Gary, man.
- Thanks.
- Thrilled to have you on.
- Thank you so much.
I'm very, very, very humbled.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Thank you.
- And I know that
you're about to run out.
But can we take a pic
for our Instagram story?
- Yeah, of course. Of course.
- Cool.
Do you mind
holding up the magazine?
- No, of course.
- [Woman 4] And Jason, you want
to get in on that?
- Yeah, sure. Sure.
Here we go.
- I'm so sorry, this is like,
- Are you kidding, I'm pumped.
- [Woman 4] On the way out.
(Jason chuckles)
- [Woman 4] Right.
Center it.
Get ready.
One, two, three.
("All I Expected to See"
by IAMCHASEON)
- How many times a day, you
get stopped with a handshake.
- As you can tell,
I'm never really outside.
But a stunning
amount considering
I'm not outside a lot, you know?
- [Woman 5] Seven,
nine, on like a regular day.
- Yeah, it's really crazy.
- [Woman 5] And
that's like a day
when you're not in
airports or something.
- Yeah, right.
- Ever not in the mood for it?
- Never.
- That'll never,
ever, ever, ever happen.
Never, to the day I die.
It's too flattering.
I can't look at it
any other way, right?
I love interacting with people.
And I'm thankful for it.
I always enjoyed it,
so it's been a really
easy transition, you know?
- [Man 3] Well you
inspired me to be social.
I wasn't really posting anything
until I saw you talk
about the 2017 Flip Challenge.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Man 3] And that's what I do.
I sell on Amazon.
I've been doin' it
for the last five years,
and I thought,
"This sounds interesting.
"Let me see what's going on."
And I saw there
was no big seller,
no one who was really an
Amazon seller or Ebay seller
who really had a
big social presence.
- [Gary] Yes.
And I was like, "Let me start
fucking around with that."
And there was a video
that you were talking about,
don't create content,
'cause I'm not gonna.
- [Gary] No, don't document.
- [Man 3] Don't, just document
what you're doing, you know?
So I started
doing that in January
and it's been
awesome ever since.
- [Gary] It's the game, right?
- [Man 3] Yeah, I built
up a nice little following
in the last couple of months.
- [Gary] Which
makes them buy your shit,
which duh duh duh...
- [Man 3] Well, I'm not
promoting my--
- [Gary] No, it
happens through osmosis.
And you got
connected with others
and stuff like that, right?
- [Man 3] Yeah, absolutely.
Rezzy Resells--
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Man 3] He came
out to New York.
Hung out the other day.
- Yeah, I saw you guys...
- [Gary] Sorry I'm late on the call.
I was in an office.
I couldn't get out of there.
I called as soon as I could.
I apologize.
("All I Expected to See"
by IAMCHASEON)
- Aha! Look at this!
Good looking guy on the
cover of a magazine? (laughs)
Damn.
- Brandon, meet Shawn.
- [Brandon] Hi Brandon,
how are you?
- Good, how are you?
Nice to meet you.
- [Brandon] Yeah, likewise.
- Shawn's been at
Vayner five years.
Now he's gonna travel the world
for a year or so for a time.
He's gonna be in Italy?
- [Shawn] Yeah.
- In late
August through October.
- [Brandon] Okay.
He, I think, potentially
wants to work a harvest or...
- Yeah.
- You wanna set up, you
wanna room, potentially,
for ten weeks in Italy.
- Mhmmm.
- Do you know what part?
- Playing with Tuscany.
- This is where I would
actually get on the phone.
This is not the normal shit
I send you where it'd be okay.
This has to happen.
- Okay.
- So, you have to
call Harmon Skurnik,
and talk to Mark De Grazia or
I don't know who you wanna--
- Got it. I got it.
- I know you know what to do.
Get him set up.
- Okay.
- Like, really proper.
I know how we do it, so instead
of the first option, like
"Oh thank God I've got this
accomplished, I can move on."
Get two options and if one's
a castle and one's a basement,
I want him to have the castle.
- Castle.
- Cause he's gonna...
- Right, no basement.
- Much easier to
get Italian girls
with a castle than a basement.
- That's true, I've heard that.
- I mean, he's got
a good face and all,
but the castle
will help. (laughing)
- A castle will blow my mind.
- "Hey, baby. I got a castle."
- Right. Exactly.
- [Shawn] Dude,
it's been five years.
So thank you, right?
I have 350 fucking
friends because of this place.
Think about that, right, like,
I wrote a thank you letter,
but you don't read
shit, so it'll be out there.
But, I wanted to tell
you straight up, right,
because it's
been five plus years.
I was a clueless kid
walking in here (Gary laughs)
and it's not just that I
learned how to be really good
at social media
or digital media,
I learned how to
solve problems, all right?
You guys saw in me
shit that I really
didn't even know was there.
You gave me the shot,
you gave me the at-bat,
and you gave me an opportunity
and then you let me do it
again, and again, and again.
Six jobs in five years in
three cities, that's crazy.
- Yes, it is.
- All under the same logo.
It's just a thank you.
- You're welcome, brother.
Listen, this
is a little reprieve
in our game, but
you're in my world for life.
- Yep.
- I feel it.
- Even as you sit here,
I'm like, ah, fuck, wait a
minute, that energy is so good.
"Go do this real quick."
It's all good stuff, man.
- You know the
last DailyVee when
you and me, we were in the cab
and you
basically kissed me here.
- [Gary] Yeah, where we
almost made out?
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- I woke up and I
woke up to these Snapchats
from random people.
I'll show you one
of them. (laughing)
I was like, "How
did you find me?"
and they literally
Snapchatted that random thing,
put hearts all over
it and they were like,
"Match made in
social media heaven."
- Just random people?
- Yeah and my handle
wasn't even in the episode,
so I don't even know how they
got it in the first place.
But, of course, they somehow
found me and decided to Snap me
the next morning and I
was like, "Okay, cool",
I need to show this to
him before I fucking dip.
- Yes.
That is the best.
- Right?
- I just saved...
Send me that picture.
- Yeah, I'll send it to you.
- I love you so much, man.
- Yeah, I love you, too.
- I'm here everyday.
- Yeah.
- Everyday you need me.
- Really gonna miss you.
- Yeah, me too.
- But in weird ways I feel like
I'll end up seeing you more.
I feel like I'm gonna
see you everywhere I travel.
- Yeah. I'll be
like, "Hey, what's up?"
- I love you, man.
- Yeah, man.
You, too.
- Good luck.
- Hit me up if you need me.
- Yeah, of course.
- All right.
- Thanks, man.
- How are you, sir?
- I'm well.
- Meet Jeff Barton.
- Hey, Jeff.
- [Jeff] How are you?
Nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure how are you?
- [Jeff] Good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- I was just telling
these guys, I travel all over.
I do recruiting.
This vibe, you can't fake that.
Those eyeballs are
so fucking real, it's...
- Just a buzz.
- You've done a lot,
but on the recruiting side
that shit is gold.
- I agree, my man,
I appreciate that.
- You know
what, I was telling (censored)
big companies change,
but it's you get in,
a week later how
quick can I get out?
I don't think I've ever seen
a resume when doing searches
up here for these young
millennials that we place.
Anyone who's ever had, you
know, Vayner anything on there.
Which is pretty insane.
- It used to be really insane.
Obviously now as
an 800 person company
you're gonna have some
level of natural attrition.
- Right, got to. Got to.
- But, I would mean in 2013...
- We don't lose people we
don't want to lose, even now--
- Right.
- Yeah!
- We're struggling to lose
people we don't want to lose.
You know what's so weird?
Literally right now, Shawn Cleo,
we had our last conversation.
- Yeah.
- Here for five years-
- It's time to roll?
- Yeah, but you
could tell, it's forever.
- Oh! How did that--
- And he's not
rolling to another company.
He's traveling the
world for a year, right?
- Yeah.
- So, it's not like he
took a job somewhere else?
- No, I mean the
amount of people that go
to another
agency is nonexistent.
- [Jeff] I don't
say any of this--
- That's absolutely right.
- to come in and make
you, I mean, I go everywhere.
Whether I'm talking
or recruiting this shit,
Just the eye,
I look at eyeballs.
You can tell when someone's
just there taking a check home.
The energy is insane.
- [AJ] I appreciate it,
man. Thank you.
- We're the right
people to fuck with.
- [Jeff] No, I get it.
That's why I
don't answer any ads.
I'm saying, I'm like,
dude, when I saw the--
- [AJ] You saw the mag?
(guys laugh)
I watch the videos.
I love all that shit.
But when I saw
the biz, I was like--
- [Gary] This is
the moment to strike.
- I had to write everything
down because I'm like
I'm not going to remember this.
- [AJ] We feel the same way.
By the way, how many
of these meetings have
Dane and I set up for you?
- This is the second.
- I think second.
- Yeah, and by the
way, we get thousands.
- [Jeff] I hear you.
- Real pleasure.
- [Jeff] Good to meet you, man.
- Yeah, real
pleasure, good luck to you.
- [Jeff] We'll see you soon.
- [Gary] Yeah, I'm
sure I'll see you soon.
- Hey man, it's good to see you.
- It's great to
see you, brother.
- How are you?
- Great, man.
- [Gary] How are
you settling in?
- Yeah, it's been a blast.
First week, or second week now.
- Going well?
- Going well, man.
- Good man, good.
- Yeah.
- We'll sit down soon.
- Okay, cool.
- What's up, man?
- [Alex] What's up? Alex.
- Alex, real pleasure, man.
- Wanted to introduce myself.
Yeah, nice to meet you.
- How you doing?
- Good.
- How's it going so far?
- Great.
- Enjoying it?
- Yeah, enjoying it a lot.
- Good man, what
are you jamming on now?
- I just put together the list
of college
players from the area.
I guess it was just
the beginning of the list.
- Yup.
- Yeah.
- I love it, man.
Looking forward to
spending some time.
- Yeah, thanks.
- Thanks for coming to say hey.
By the way, did
you guys hear that
Justin thought he was
going to beat me in hockey?
- [Man 4] I've
been watching him play
every day for
the last two weeks.
- Justin?
- [Man 4] Yeah, so the
fact that you beat him,
I was disappointed in Justin.
- [Gary] To be honest,
I actually thought
he was playing well.
- [Justin] I know a
lot of good goalie plays.
- You did, and I thought you
were playing well overall.
- [Man 4] But, you lost.
- I'm like all time.
So, I wanted to
get everybody together
because I wanted
to kind of make sure
our tech lead, John,
and your tech lead, Wes,
and then all the business
people here were aligned.
I want to kind of cross
every T and dot every I.
The ambition
for me is, and John,
we'll have to talk,
Danny's family,
which then makes (censored).
This is all family.
You know me.
We've always built things.
Back in 1996, we built things
because I hated being at
the mercy of other things.
The only thing that
we're at the mercy of
is our POS system,
and we hate it
with all our heart, right?
This is the thing, right?
However, my dream would be
to hack the (censored)
natural product to be a version
of our club card that
we've been chasing for years.
John K, I've got
design capabilities here
for you if you need them.
Let's move.
Tell me what you need.
Send me a URL to scanners.
I'm ready to go.
- [John K] Okay,
we just need to talk
about API a little bit.
- Yeah, you and Wes nerd it up,
but let's go full
steam ahead, great.
- [John K] Okay, I'll
type your email on the invite.
- All right, I'm
going to go to the thing.
I have to go.
I'm going to send
my latest captive.
Thanks, Danny,
I'm looking forward,
I'm looking forward to it.
- Gar, what's up, man?
- [Gary] Such a
pleasure, all right, thanks.
- Thanks for having us.
- [Gary] I'm
thrilled to be here.
What's up, what's up?
How you guys doing?
- [Man 5] We're
thrilled to be here, man.
Thanks so much
for even having us.
I was--
- You fucking hacked me, bro.
Hey, Reynolds, can
I ask you a question?
If I paid for the bus,
I know schools are fucked up,
so they can't take advantage,
but if I paid for the bus,
can you bring like
eight or nine of them up here
and hang with me for an hour?
I couldn't wait
for this day to happen,
so I'm really happy you're here.
Listen, I'll be honest.
I can give you
guys a little context.
Do you guys have any idea who
I am or anything about me?
- [Man 6] Yes.
- Okay great, so,
to be real honest,
I'd love to maximize our time
together, answer shit for you.
Maybe I'll talk a little bit,
just to create
some framework, right?
But, to me, I'd love to
just answer any questions
you guys might have
or things of that nature.
Here's my perspective.
My big thing, you know
what caught my attention
about what you
were talking about,
which is I'm fascinated
by the game
of opportunity, right?
I think when you get
into these conversations,
like who's got opportunity?
Who's born, who wins the lottery
of being born into a
trust fund, who doesn't?
Who grows up in
a bad neighborhood?
There's people
live in the Amazon.
There's a lot going on with the
7.7 billion people on Earth.
To me, the game of opportunity
is what's super fascinating,
and I think the internet
just fucked everything up
in the best way possible.
There's just so
much more opportunity
than there ever was
for the people that don't
have the opportunity,
and to me that's like fuck.
That's something you need to
really wrap your head around.
I say that to people that have
everything handed to them,
and people that have
nothing handed to them.
- So, you talk a lot about
self-awareness
and knowing yourself.
What does that mean
for young people that
have had a hard life,
or deal with a lot
of different things that kids
shouldn't deal with at this age.
I know self-awareness
in knowing yourself,
but what are your
thoughts when you're trying
to figure out yourself,
and you have to kind of
deal with the
baggage in your life?
You know, I never hear
you talk about counseling
or anything like that,
so I'm just wondering
your thoughts on
more about self-awareness
for these guys
I'm interested in.
- [Gary] Look I think
people that are growing up
in the best
environments of all time
are struggling with
self-awareness at 13 and 14.
- [Woman 4] Sure.
- I mean 98% of my company are
in their 30s and 40s and 20s,
have no clue on self-awareness.
So here's what I would say.
I would say that I'm a big
fan of just eating reality.
I'm just a fan of it, you know.
The reality was I was never,
I had my dad, but I didn't
'cause he worked every hour.
Never saw him,
missed every game,
just didn't see him,
worked every hour.
I was happy, it was
way better than him leaving
or dying or, it was great,
but I didn't have him.
I could've done
what my other friends
who have workaholic
parents do and dwelled,
be like, "My dad's not at my
baseball game." or you don't.
Look, I am not going
to short change
the extremities of
all the things, all the
cliches, parents, drugs,
murder, mental health,
all the things.
The thing that
I have not figured out
is how to get the
universe to give a fuck.
So to answer your question,
it's amazing to see people
in good situations
and bad situations
go through a
situation and do this.
If I could everybody a
drug it would be optimism.
Right, if you're willing
to look at all your shit,
whatever it is, and by
the way, everybody thinks
their shit is the shit.
Right?
I've had people
sit in this room,
one by one with me say,
"If my dad didn't give me
"a $100 million
I would've never been a loser
"'cause it all
came to easy to me."
Everybody thinks
their shit's the shit
'cause it's their life. Right?
People that don't
have parents and things,
they laugh at that,
they're like, "Fuck you."
But that person
thinks that's the shit.
So it's about, I don't know.
I don't talk about a
lot of things I don't know,
I don't know how to
recommend counseling
or how to build self-awareness
or mental health,
I try to stay away from
things that I don't know
'cause I think that
would be detrimental
to the things I do know.
What I will say is,
so I don't know how
to teach self-awareness,
I just know it's the most,
I just know it's the game.
Once you know who you are it
manifests into self esteem.
You don't actually
then give a fuck what,
you know you sit here
and just don't give a fuck
what they say or you
just don't care, it's crazy
when you get there.
That's like the
fucking ultimate,
you're just fucking
living life in the matrix.
You're just running through,
to actually not give a,
especially at this age,
that's what happened to me.
I still think about it,
how the fuck did
I not give a fuck?
(group laughter)
Right? Because it's like,
when you're like 13, 14, 15
that's you whole life,
I just remember not caring,
I was just on some
different shit in my head.
So that's what
I want for everybody
because then you're fucking set.
- [Man 7] How do you get there?
- I don't know man.
That's why
I don't talk about it. Right?
I just honestly, I swear to
God, if I knew how to get there
this whole
thing would be a wrap.
I'd own the Jets.
I'd own the world
if I knew how to get there
and get people there right.
I try to get there
by talking about it,
and maybe
somebody's like, "Oh shit
"that's kinda like me too,
let me go deeper into that.
"I actually do feel like that,
"I actually don't give a fuck."
I don't know, but God it's big.
'Cause then peer pressure's out,
then you're just not
getting dragged into anything
you don't wanna be doing.
- Alright, so, you know
how you, you boast about
having all this
technology and everything.
So you're saying now
I won't have to do things
that people's parents
might do, like deal drugs
or go out there in
the street and do whatever
'cause we got so much of
this we can make more money
doing, flipping
simple stuff and just
going out and earning it.
So like, so you
could just take any steps,
like this is
gonna maybe 100 times,
but you'll probably
get it sooner or later.
- My belief is that if
you're a great drug dealer,
you'd be a great businessman.
I just believe that
'cause it's the same game.
You're selling,
you're working it,
like, listen the only friends
I had were drug dealers.
If you're good
at that, I'm saying,
there's a lot of drug
dealers that suck at it.
(group laughter)
Right?
Right? Right?
Listen, I made, all
the kids that I really
hung onto in friendships,
I'm like look at my man,
he's breaking down these bags
into nickles because he's
making more money that way
and he's chinsing,
he's actually making
$3 bags but he realizes
that everybody at the school
doesn't know the fucking
difference and doesn't care.
He's smart, and then
I would see other people
who would buy an ounce and
smoke 3/4 of it in four minutes
and then be bad at flipping in,
I was like he's
a fucking loser so
if you're good at it,
or if somebody's good at it,
they'd be even
better at flipping sneakers
or gear or going to the
thrift store and flipping
because it's the
same fucking move.
And then when you have the
freedom of being not scared
to get caught, now
you're fucking fast.
Because when you're selling
drugs, you gotta think about
that extra dimension
of getting caught.
But when you're
selling fucking t-shirts,
now you're a
fucking entrepreneur
and everyone thinks, you know,
people put you on a pedestal.
So yes, I believe that.
(group laughter)
- I love him, I love him.
- I believe it!
'Cause it's true.
'Cause it's fucking true.
Because the kids that
I knew that sold drugs for real
and were real good at
it, have gone on to be
much more successful in the
world than the ones that didn't.
Like it's just a hustle.
You've got people skills.
You see angles.
That's the same
shit that's like, fuck,
this thrift store keeps getting
their fucking merchandise
and they put it out at
9:30 in the morning,
I'm gonna go there cause,
there might be some Nike's.
But it's just hard work.
But I think, like when you
realize how much more money
you can make, how much good
can happen from hard work,
everybody's
willing to put in the hard...
If I was a real genie,
or a real fucking Yoda,
then I was like, yo,
check this out, watch this,
and you saw you, you
know, fuck, what the fuck?
And you saw you,
and it's like a good life,
and I'm like
here's all you gotta do,
you gotta work 15
hours a day, right now,
for the next ten years
straight, you'll do it.
Everybody will do it.
People don't do it cause
they're not sure what's on the
other side of it.
'Cause they said no
before they said yes.
My big thing is like,
you're either gonna
define yourself for yourself
or you're gonna let
somebody else define you.
You're either gonna
let your mom define you,
your dad define you,
your grandparents define you,
your older brother,
your older sister,
dude from around the way.
You know,
somebody's gonna define you,
or you're gonna define yourself.
I'm just trying to
figure out how to hack at you,
to make you define yourself
for yourself in yourself
within yourself,
and then shit changes.
- Gary, you got this?
I like to give people pictures
of my face sometimes.
(group laughter)
- [Man 6] All the
guys signed it.
- [Gary] I love this
- [Man 6] And just
to say, thanks.
- [Gary] I appreciate this,
my man. Good luck to you.
I'll do better than
that, you know what.
Come with me to my office,
I'll let them sign up,
I'll sign you guys all a book.
- [Gary] Thank you my man.
- [Woman 5]
Alright ready guys? We're good.
One two three,
(indistinct chatter)
- [Gary] I'm telling you my
man, what I told you is truth.
Listen, the truth.
It's crazy. It's just real.
- I know it's all real.
- It's just real, you know?
Listen, making $18 a day
selling chochktas vs making a
hundred, it's hard at first,
but if you just fucking hold
your breath you can get there.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 254
of The #AskGaryVee Show,
and this is a very,
very, very special episode
because the all time most
popular guest of my original
video and podcast show back
in the day, Wine Library TV,
was none other than my dad
Sasha Vaynerchuk, who is here,
looking dapper Dad.
- Hello.
- [Gary] You threw
up a deuce. I like that.
And, who is now making
his second appearance on
The #AskGaryVee Show, yeah,
remember we got emotional,
Andy was there, we
were playing basketball,
we had this great episode.
- Oh yes.
- [Gary] What
episode was that? Anybody?
- [Andy] 118
- This guy is on it.
- [Sasha] Wow I'm impressed.
- [Gary] Andy's very impressive.
- Can you send it to me please?
- Yeah, it's a real good one.
- You should ask him about
his parking ticket in Boston.
- Oh! That's not a
story anyone knows.
So, in Boston, my
junior year, on Comm Ave,
there was nowhere to really
park, so, it was super hard.
So I would just park in
places, I ended up with like,
six, what do you think, 40?
- Guys, his, what is it?
- [Gary] Glove compartment.
- Glove compartment
when you opened,
all the parking tickets
for, it's got to be over
a hundred parking tickets.
- Yeah. Good thing
we didn't tell mom.
- He, he came to me,
and being a tough father,
you know what everybody thinks,
I paid all the tickets.
- Yeah, you're only
tough on the outside.
- [Sasha] Right.
- Super soft on the inside.
- So I paid all the tickets.
- [Gary] That's right.
You like that Iris?
- And what about the
$10,000 club deal?
- Don't, we're not
going into that story.
(group laughter)
That's story's not coming out.
That story's
definitely not coming out.
That was a business expense.
(Gary and Sasha laugh)
Andy get to questions before
Dad gets too out of control!
I love you Dad.
- I love you.
- Thank you, give me a kiss.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
- And I'll have a little more.
("The Pioneer Banjoneer"
by Hubris)
- [Marcus] We're here
with the Office of the CEO.
We're meeting
with Gary basically to
give him updates on
projects that we're working on,
catch up on things on his end,
see if there's anything
that he needs us to do.
He's traveling a lot
over the next couple of months
so we've been chatting with him
about just
building a cadence so that
whether he's here and we're
meeting with him in person
or whether we're just
setting up phone calls,
that we just set
some degree of a cadence
on just keeping in touch
so we can make sure we
don't lose any momentum.
- [Gary] I hate him
with all my heart,
but I'm Michael Jordan.
And you should
let Michael Jordan
take the last shot in the game,
and it's been the
biggest eye-opener for me,
which is I am such
not a micro-manager.
I want to let everybody do,
but what manifests from
that is it gets away from me.
People don't get it.
To the email,
this kid you want me to meet,
I don't...
We need everybody,
If everybody knew who I was,
we'd be rolling.
If they really knew.
And I think we need to
be smart about scaling me.
So that's what I would chall--
Always think
about what that means.
Whatever the fuck that means.
Whether that
means you scaling me.
means you being like,
you defending me.
Whether you tell
me I should this,
I mean this has been great.
This matters.
Give me one second so
I can look at how behind I am,
and what I have next,
and then we'll
take it from this.
- [Man 9] Is everyone
doing all right in here?
("The Pioneer Banjoneer"
by Hubrist)
- This is not a joke.
In 2007, me and AJ are up
at like four
o'clock in the morning
building some
cockamamie website,
and my brother,
my brother
looked at me and said,
"Bro, you can tell me.
"Like, I won't tell anyone.
"You're my brother, I love you.
"Are you a robot?"
(group chuckles)
Are you a robot?
He's like, "I won't
tell the authorities.
"You don't pee, drink, eat,
"and you're on
24/7/365 straight."
Cool.
- You're not, are you?
- What?
- [Man 10] Are you a robot?
- No. (laughs)
Thank you guys so
much for coming out.
- Thanks very much.
- You guys enjoyed it?
- Yeah
- It was fun right?
- It was nice.
- Wonderful dinner.
- Good.
I appreciate it.
I'm a huge fan. I think,
I actually now believe,
as I continue to do homework,
that the
convergence of VR and AR
is actually what happens.
- Mixed reality.
- Yeah.
You believe in that?
- Mixed reality,
artificial intelligence,
I don't think people
understand how all this stuff
is getting lumped,--
- [Gary] Correct.
- into one technology.
- [Gary] It's because most
people don't understand
how tech talks to
each other, right?
They don't understand API.
They don't understand.
They don't understand
the scaled smartification
of our society.
They don't understand.
They don't understand
that like a week
after I started using Alexa,
I started using Siri.
Where guys like you and I lose,
is on timing.
- [Man 11] (laughs) Yes!
- That's where--
- [Man 11] I have 360
rings I can throw right now.
- That's where I matured
in the last 25 years.
1994, GaryVee
would have been like,
"Oh my God, this is next week,
"tomorrow."
I did it.
I launched an
e-commerce wine business
in 1996 because
by the year of 1998,
everybody's gonna
buy wine on the internet.
I learned that game.
So, pleasure.
- [Man 11] Yeah,
thank you so much.
- So nice to meet you, yeah.
- [Woman 7] Thank you.
- Hey guys.
- I loved hearing you.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Woman 8] I'd love to
pitch you my idea some day.
- I'm Gary at VaynerMedia.
We do,
- You are.
- That's what
we do for a living.
We go through 'em.
- [Woman 8] We've got this,
We're trying to build
this Tamagochi, digital pet.
- You've already
got my attention.
(man laughs)
- So we're gonna,
- Seriously.
- [Woman 8] If you
love your Tamagochi,
from like,--
- You've got my attention.
- [Woman 8] We're
trying to do that.
Okay.
We'll be in touch.
- Cool. Awesome.
It's 10:43, I'm wrapping up.
I'm going to an HBO event
that they're not
letting Justin in.
Justin, I hope
you enjoy the day.
- [Justin] Good day.
- Yeah, you get to go home.
Bubble hockey, you lost 4-1?
- [Justin] 4-1.
- Yeah, that was a
tough loss for you.
And I'll see you guys tomorrow.
("The Pioneer Banjoneer"
by Hubris)